This spring, denim gets a softer, lighter update. Introducing Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg, a new fit that moves with you. It's everything you want denim to feel like for summer. Easy, breathable, and effortlessly cool. With a fit that creates natural movement and a wide leg that feels modern, not overwhelming. Plus, that signature, wait, for this price, moment. Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg. Hi, everybody. Welcome to the Rest is History.
have a brand new mini-series for you to mark the FIFA World Cup, which is happening in the United States, Canada and Mexico. So what we're going to be doing is looking at some of the history, the deep history of the World Cup, and in particular the story of how dictatorships have used football and used the World Cup in particular to bolster support for their regimes. So we're looking at propaganda, we're looking at the personalities of the dictators, we'll be looking at the stories of the tournaments and how they reflect public opinion and so on. some amazing stories. In future episodes, we'll be looking at the great Brazilian team of the 1960s and early 1970s. That's the team of Palais and Jezino and Jetson and all these great players. The team that won in 1970, people say the best team of all time. But this was a point when Brazil had a military dictatorship. So we'll be looking at the military dictatorship of Brazil from 1964 uses football. We'll be looking at arguably the most controversial World Cup of All, which is 1978 Argentina. Some of you may remember we did a series about Eva Perron, and this is effective with the sequel to that.
So we'll be looking at the military junta of the late 70s and how they used the 78 World Cup and the team of Mario Kempes, which won against the Dutch in the final. Big, big story in Argentina. But we'll be kicking off with Italy and with Mussolini's fascist regime and the World Cups of 1934 and 1938. So it's a really, really great subject.
Now, we love our listeners. So this is a special treat to mark the World Cup. Normally this episode would be a bonus episode purely for members of the Restis History Club. But because it is the summer of sport, we are making this first episode in the series with the brilliant Paul Rouse available to everybody. And if you want to hear the rest of the series,
which I hope you will, you merely have to go, you know the drill, to the rest is history.com to sign up and you'll get not only Paul's wisdom about Brazil in the 1960s and 70s and Argentina in 1978. But you'll get all the usual things, you'll get early access to series, you'll get bonus episodes,
and an unbelievable range of supplementary benefits. So what's not to like? If you're not interested in football, don't worry, the history will very much be uppermost. A great subject needs a great guest. We have the greatest. We have the goat, as we like to call him, the self-styled Irish national treasure.
No. I'm a professor of history. at University College, Dublin. Paul Rouse. Paul, welcome back to the rest of history. It's great to have you on. Thanks, William, Dominic. Because it's a football story,
we've chosen this lovely location. Thanks to Chelsea Football Club, we're here at Stamford Bridge overlooking the pitch. And with perfect timing, impeccable timing, Chelsea have decided today to rip up the pitch and do loads of building work on the stadium.
So, Paul, you will be competing with reversing vehicles, diggers, bulldozers, general men in kind of yellow vests. But you're pumped for that, right? I'm ready. You're ready. Brilliant.
So, Paul, you were masquerading as a historian of Ireland in the last few series that we did. But this really is your home turf, isn't it? Because you're a historian of sport. Is that right? That's what I spend most of my time teaching and working on in University of College Dublin is the history of sport. Yeah. Nationally in Ireland, but also internationally, I teach a second year module on the global history of sport. Yeah.
Across the last 250 years in particular. Lots to talk about here. And obviously it's very much in the news at the moment, the World Cup and politics. because the World Cup is being held in the US. Donald Trump has tried to take ownership of it. There have been a number of scandals. The Iran players had to move their base from the US to Mexico, business with a referee not being allowed in this time.
Do you think this is something new, or an example of how football has always been politicised and used by political leaders of one kind or another? The idea of soccer being politicised is nothing at all new. What is new is the precise manner in which it's revealed, itself. In the case of America, I suppose, the Trumpist focus on immigration and on the projection of America first. And that is in collision with the expressed hashtag, if you look at Gianni Infantino, the head of FIFA's Instagram page, he seems to be unable to post without putting the hashtag
football unites the world. And unfortunately, you cannot say that football unites the world if at the same time you're denying entry into your country of people because of where they come from and including in that a referee of the competition but again this is not new the whole way through from 1930 and like this is a political story
the whole way through the relationship and there was a president of FIFA an English man in the 50s and 60s Stanley Rouse no relation he'd know he in his name he had this whole notion that sport and politics and soccer and politics in particular should not be put into the same wheelhouse
but they've always been there. Yeah, so I agree with you. I think sport's always been political. It's always been used by, you know, going back to the Victorians, it's always been used by people in authority and power to project the values they want to project. Now, one thing I do notice is that you've used
a very controversial word a couple of times that some of our British listeners will already be bridling about, even though it's in origin, a British word. And that word is the dresser. I did word, soccer. So for our British and American listeners who are clearly going to be divided on this issue, you think it's fair to call football soccer, right?
Well, in my world, it's logical to do it. And you're right, there is an amazing internet fight or people running around the internet with pitchforks. It is quite remarkable. But if you look at the word, the word comes from England that was used in England from the 1890s onwards, all the way through to the 1980s, in research. for this series, I went back and I looked at preview shows of the World Cup and 1978 preview show, Kevin Keegan refers to soccer in his ITV punditry. On the title page of Matt Busby's autobiography from 1973, soccer and football is used interchangeably. This is something that changed
in the 1990s, but in a world where we consider that there are sports which exist beyond this island, the island on which we are filming, there are other forms. football games. So as shorthand, I call association football soccer but in the town I'm from, Tullamore and awfully, football is Gaelic football. I'm sure as people have loads of infuriated
comments about this one way or another, so we'll let them argue about it. But let's get into our story. So today's episode is about Italy and the 1930s in particular and Mussolini. So if we start with Mussolini in Italian fascism, Mussolini
comes to power in October 1922. They've had march on Rome, which, of course, Mussolini wasn't, you know, he sits and watches the march on Rome. And then he's come to power. It's a backlash against the sort of the red years, or whatever they are in the early 1920s, so labor unrest, there's the scars of the First World War, there are a lot of disaffected veterans and so on. Manliness, virility, national unity, these are all parts of Mussolini's agenda, aren't they? How much of Mussolini and fascism? How much of the appeal of that you think comes down to kind of an aura of masculinity, I guess. Well, Mussolini was promising a new world and he looked for a distinction from what he
considered the failed regime. This is a Trident-tested technique across the world from regimes who seek to start anew. They present the old world as being failed. They present it as being a dying country full of people who were just weak. And Mussolini to an almost cartoonish extent, tried to project virility, tried to project energy and dynamism and discipline and health. And this was in contradistinction to what had been there previously. And it led to when you see the footage now of Mussolini or you see the photographs of him, it's almost, it's almost cartoonish in its exaggerated nature in the histrionics were there. But it must never be forgotten the extent to which he was a cruel and brutal individual, truly ruthless in what he wished to do
and the fact that almost from the beginning he wanted war. But sport was part of the whole projection of what he was trying to do in creating, as he saw it and knew Italy. So there are sort of two elements to that, aren't there, I think. One is, I mean, you mentioned health. So the idea of the health of the nation reviving what is a sick and dying country under democracy, failed democracies, and sport becomes a projection or a reflection of the health of society, but also sport is training for war, that sport is training you in the discipline and the competitiveness and the aggression that you need to attack Abyssinia or Greece or whoever it might be.
The way they did it was twofold, it was threefold, really. The projection of Mussolini himself as the country's greatest sportsman, this imagery of him out skiing bare-chested and out riding horses and there's images of him. He looks terrible on a bicycle, but there's a brilliant photograph of him standing on a balcony with loads of Italian cyclists
waving their bikes in the air. It's an incredible image. And the truth of it is, he was anything but athletic. He was a small, fat man when it comes down to it. And he was not... Nothing wrong with that, Paul.
No, no. He was athletic in no modern sense of the word that you would consider, although he wanted to project the idea that he was. But he went for practical policies around it. And you look at the building of sports fields through the late 20s into the 30s, an extra 3,000 sports fields built around Italy in the world. Because he was looking for mass participation in sport. But he also put gyms and sports halls in villages and in towns around the place. So this was a vast, ultimately fascist project to create men. And it was directed towards men or there were women involved in sport who would be able to people, an army. And then the third layer was. the development of a kind of an elite sporting world in which there would be elite sport within Italy,
but really that the best Italian sports people would be able to compete in cycling and in boxing and ultimately in soccer and in the Olympic Games when they went outside the country. So just a question before we move on about this. How much of this do you think is reflecting a new kind of dictatorship? So there have been dictatorships before, but in the 1920s and 1930s, what you see in the USSR in Italy, obviously in Nazi Germany in the 1930s, is the development of what we'd call totalitarianism. So the idea that top-down politics will invade every aspect of life and leisure and recreation are absolutely central parts of this. If you've got a new sports hall in your village or you've got a new running track or a cycling track or whatever, You know, how much do you think that is, it's simply what governments do? It's part of national welfare that's promoted everywhere in the 20th century.
And how much is it distinctively, well, either totalitarian or distinctively fascist? I think the scale of it makes it distinct. And you're right. It's an attempt to push into every aspect of life. And what better way, if you want to look at the hours between when people are working and sleeping or in school and sleeping, if you take that chunk of time for a lot of people, it's an engagement in sport? It's both an opportunity to channel people in certain directions, but also an opportunity to channel their behavior as well.
So you got in the case of Italy the development of mass sporting movements, which happened in two ways. First of all, it's the suppression and the destruction or the colonization of organizations that were run by the communists in Italy or by the Catholic Church and their identification with the new regime. And then the creation of a youth sports movement, Sport and Leisure Movement, more broadly, on an adult one, which attempted to draw Italians in, to not just develop the body in a certain way, but to get them to identify with the regime
which was there being constructed by Mussolini. And one element of this actually, I know from your notes, and it actually runs through all three of the stories we'll do is involvement in the Army, because the Army in Italy are training physical instructors, aren't they? in Brazil. I mean, actually the Brazilian football manager in the 1970s, Claudio Coutinho was a captain in the Brazilian army.
And then obviously the army in Argentina using the 1978 victory. So do you think there's an obviously militaristic side to this? And would that have been obvious to Italians in 1930 or something? Well, the teachers who were being trained were being trained by army instructors
who were brought in and you can see by these army officers who trained the, physical fitness instructors who are going around the place produced by 1936, there were 14,000 such instructors produced from these army academies. And I think it's interesting. We'll see this later on. But you look at the Argentinian, in particular, with Perron, he was in Italy in these years. He saw what was happening and he adopted this broader, sporting, approach to sport and the engagement with the army that he had witnessed in Italy during these years.
That's so interesting. So much of it comes back to this model, doesn't it, the kind of Italian fascist model that is then copied in South America in the post-war years. It's not as discredited as it is in Europe, maybe, I guess. No, but when we go through this later on, you can see these ideas that were replicated. I mean, what happened in Italy in the 20s and 30s? These notions expanded, and sport is part, or they were exported, I mean, and part of that is what happened in South America after the war. Now, you talked about one big element of this. It's not just about internal stuff, but it's about the projection of Italian fascism abroad, using sport to project it.
So how does that work? So, for example, this is the era of the Olympic Games are taking Ruth and whatnot. The Italians, I mean, they're wearing black shirts at the Olympic Games, things like that. There's an obviously fascistic element to this and there's an element that we're, even in the 20s, Mussolini is trying to use
sporting triumphs abroad to bolster his regime at home. It's not that Mussolini arrived in 1922 when there was the immediate creation of a fascist state. This was change that happened, a lot of change, but it happened through the 20s. So you have by the end of the 1920, 1928, Landreau Ferretti, who is the head of the Italian Olympic Committee, talked about this idea of using the movement to create courageous soldiers in wartime. By 32, the Italians are parading at the Olympic Games in
LA wearing black shirts, and they did really well. They came second in the medals table, which is a huge step forward. And even in 36 in Berlin, the Italians came forth. So this is a movement that is really gathering momentum in terms of Italian prestige on the world's sporting stage. Probably the most famous person in the world in the 1930s was the world heavyweight champion, whoever that was at a particular year. And Primo Carnera, the Italian boxer, won the world heavyweight championship in 1933. And his fame was promoted through newsreels and through radio, which was then beginning to broadcast live fights and disperse them across.
the population reaching into people's homes as well as in squares. And of course, in cycling, you had the Giro, the Italia. Cycling was the biggest sport in Italy in the 1930s. And the Giro was hugely important. So you have between that and the modern sport of motorcar racing where Italian drivers, Italy isn't just staging races. It's sending out some of the best drivers in the world. So you see the whole creation of an international sporting presence for Italy,
which had not previously been the case. So you've talked about boxing, cycling. I mean, they're very emblematic sports of the 1920s and 1930s, but not yet, as you would call it, soccer. I mean, the great irony, of course, is that Mussolini does not himself like football, but he's very good at using it. Is that because it's already very popular and very well established in Italy, or is the development of football in Italy something... I mean, obviously, football has been spread by the British in the late 19th century, sailors, railwaymen, you know, the classic story, the sons of industrialists who went to... public schools and then just did a few, you know, a few months in Montseverdeo and took a ball with them or whatever. How well established is football in Italy in this point in the 20s?
The story of the game on European soil is the story of incredible explosion across much of Europe in the 20s and in the 30s. It was hugely popular, we'll say, in Hungary, in Austria. But in Italy, it took off in the 1920s. Now, there had been soccer played from the 1890s and your right is the story of expats and traders and soldiers and sailors bringing it wherever they went, but it's also the story of Italians who went to work in England. So you see some of the main people will see it with Pazzo, the great Italian manager of the 30s. He loved the game and he got it because he was sent by his family textile trade to work in the north of England. He ended up befriending Mansi United players and managers. But that connection of commerce and of finance of trade
The story of the game on European soil is the story of incredible explosion across much of Europe in the 20s and in the 30s. It was hugely popular, we'll say, in Hungary, in Austria. But in Italy, it took off in the 1920s. Now, there had been soccer played from the 1890s and your right is the story of expats and traders and sailors bringing it wherever they went, but it's also the story of Italians who went to work in England. So you see some of the main people will see it with Pazzo, the great Italian manager of the 30s. He loved the game and he got it because he was sent by his family textile trade to work in the north of England. He ended up befriending Mansi United players and managers. But that connection of commerce and of finance of trade
is important and you get an anglophilia of people who just think England is the most modern country in the world will adopt the game and then there's the joy of playing. So you had the first clubs in the 1890s and before the war you had Italian clubs being established playing games with each other
hugely influenced by England but after the 1920s you had an explosion of interest in the game. You get the broader commercialisation with the building of grounds because such was the interest in people, not just playing, but also now watching others play.
And crucially, the identification of clubs with areas and with towns and with cities. And it became a matter of civic pride to have a decent team to represent you, to compete in the championship. And what Mussolini did was to oversee, through his men, who were out into various organizations,
was to essentially take control of Italian soccer by organising the establishment in no particular order of the amalgamation of some clubs in some city so they would have a really strong presence. Number two, the establishment of an Italian league. Number three, the devotion of greater focus to the Italian national team. And number four, the acceptance, though not the outward acknowledgments of professionalism. It said that you could have non-amateurs playing in your clubs. So this is the shift from amateurism to professionalism, all of which took place in the 1920s. So interesting.
And a couple of elements of this I think are really interesting. So one is the teams that we now regard as the canonical Italian teams, some of these are Mussolini-era creations. They are the one thing that football fans now hate is inauthentic. They are made-up teams, contrived teams, you know, the authorities have forced different clubs to amalgamy. So I was astounded to Fiorentina, Roma, Napoli, these are all basically
made up clubs in the 1920s and 30s. Top down. Top down. And it could have gone either ways. Like you look at what happened to Welsh rugby after clubs were forced together
in the wake of professionalism in the middle of the 1990s and the struggles of Welsh rugby to drive itself forward again. The complete opposite was experienced in Italy where clubs were forcibly merged under fascist leadership,
but they provided a spectacle that was only in the making at that stage. You must remember that that world of the 1920s, it's not like there was generational devotion to a particular club. What this is is a new world which has been forged at that world of commercial sport, based around associational culture as well
where people are joining clubs, and it becomes more of a modern thing to do in the 1930s, in particular from the early 1930s onwards with the establishment. of the Italian League and Cup, and the fact that there was a rail system which allowed people to travel the country,
both to play games and to support the teams that were representing their city. You know, infrastructure promotes the act of supporting, doesn't it? You can't support your team home and away unless you can get to Napoli or Florence or wherever. And I guess that, without that, that wouldn't have been possible. Without it, you just couldn't do it.
And look, the birth of modern sport, the construction of all of these things is made possible by the modern technologies of transport and international sport is not possible without the steamship and then the airplane but it's also about new media technologies so it's newspapers and the dedication now of the sporting press in Italy
which advertises these games, reports on them, creates that celebrity culture around the best sport so people can read the preview, read the report, get the creation of stars and identify during the week
with the team which they see play at the weekend. That's so interesting. Because actually when I think even about how I experienced football growing up in the 70s and 80s, I didn't go to games. There weren't that many games on TV. For me, it was actually, this is a weird thing to say about football. It was a reading experience. I read about games in the newspaper and I followed the narrative every day.
And it was a kind of continuous textual narrative rather than something that I... To see a game on TV was very exciting because they weren't on very often. And presumably you had the comic books as well. it's Roy the Rovers and everything that that goes with that. And Roy of the Rovers famously the most unlucky man in sport. Yeah. So many plane crashes. So many playing crashes.
And they could not go on a South American tour without arriving to see that there was a new Hoon place in the... There was been kidnapped. They just, it was really difficult. And then to lose a leg in a bomb explosion was for a soccer player quite challenging. Exactly. Now, actually, you mentioned steamships and international travel. One aspect of this, I'm slightly jumping ahead. Does the Italian League have foreign players in the 1930s?
Yes, it does. And the story of how this happened is, I suppose, it's the birth of an international transfer market in a significant way. The president of Torino, FC, Enrico Maroni, who was a very wealthy businessman, was in Argentina on a business trip, and he saw a player called Julio Libanati, who was the son of Italian immigrants, and he went and he said,
I'm bringing this guy back to my club. He had played for Argentina, won the Cup of Sudamerica for what became the Cup of America for Argentina, and he won the Italian championship for Torino by virtue of his performances. So what you then had was between 1929 and the early 1940s, more than 100 South Americans, arrive, well, that's like they decided to go. They were head hunted from, not just from Argentina, but also from Uruguay and Brazil and Paraguay. And they were
brought in to do this. And these were the sons of Italian emigrants. Because of Italian emigration to South America had been enormous at the end of the 19th century in the early 20th century. So these were brought in. These were the Rimpatriati. this sun. So this way, so you have a problem in, if you're a fascist in Italy, because you're talking about the blood, you're talking about the importance of a kind of an Italy first to project backwards from America, this idea that the Italian nation must be preserved and developed and rendered more dynamic. So how do you square that with the bringing in of people from abroad? And what you do is you find the children of Italian immigrants and you bring them home and
they're acceptable. Yeah. Because their parents are Italian. Now, I know it's risky asking this of an Irishman who must have supported Jack Charlton's Island team in the 1990s, which of course was full of Englishmen. But are they inventing Italian ancestry for these people, Tony Cascarino style? Because that's what you guys did with Tony Cascarino. I think that's, Tony Cascarino's autobiography made that claim. But I think it subsequently was proven afterwards that he did actually have the entitlement to a passport. Now, it is absolutely true that the Irish FAA Football Association of Ireland courted. foreigners.
A creative not foreigners, but people born to the diaspora who may not have had a deep connection. A creative attitude to genealogy,
I think is. Which in fair, but like, so I'm not going to be defensive on this because there is not a country in the world that doesn't do this. Look at the English cricket
and rugby teams that have produced people over the last one. I wish Tom was here to defend what happened in cricket. All right. So let's get to the World Cup. Italy didn't play in the first. World Cup, which is in 1930. The First World Cup is held in Uruguay. We did an episode about it in 2022,
where we talked about the origins of the World Cup. At that point, it's not obvious. It's going to become a massive international event. People are traveling by steamboats cross the Atlantic. England, of course, don't go. Argentina and Uruguay play out the first final, which Uruguay wins in Monte Valle. There's the famous stories about people crossing the river plate on chips. And getting lost in the fog and not making the game. Exactly. But 1934 is going to be held in Italy. And from the start, the fascist authorities see this as a, this is their equivalent, I suppose, in some ways, something we'll talk about in a little bit, which is the 1936 Olympics. This is going to be a showcase for fascism. Basically, they want to ensure that Italy win, right? So how do they go about doing that? So they do a range of different things. If we look, first of all, at the purpose of it. of the competition.
So Giorgio Vaccaro, who was the head of the Football of Federation in Italy, said that the World Cup was a chance to show the organizational efficiency of fascist sport in general and football in particular.
And he talked about this opportunity to display also Italian manhood on the world stage. So the Italian newspapers who covered it, they put it on their front pages because they were instructed to do so by the propaganda ministry and the Italian diplomatic corps went into overdrive around the world,
trying to get newspapers around the world to do the same. Secondly, new stadiums were constructed. I lived in Florence for a couple of years, about 25 years ago, and played soccer on the fields right beside in Cocherno and beside the Fjantina, the Stadio Comenale in Fiorantina. And that stadium still stood, but that was built at the time. The one in Bologna had a statue of Mussolini on. horse at the back of the stadium looking down across everything. They did a third thing.
They wanted people to come and to see what Italy was like. So they basically invented tourist packages for people to come to the World Cup and subsidise travel to Italy and between the cities on the rail within Italy. They arranged this brilliant radio infrastructure. So radio was pushing into people's homes by the early 1930s. But the Italians had more than that. They erected loudspeakers on poles in the main squares of villages and towns and in cities and in their suburbs. And the games were also relayed to 12 competing countries around the place.
So the technology was only developing in terms of international relay, but for European countries, it was straightforward. The fascist symbol was everywhere. It was put on tickets. And the tickets were designed and printed to a really high standard. so the people could bring them home with them. So this is the construction of a memorabilia, this iconography of the World Cup, and the Italians were right at the heart,
所以当时的技术只在国际转播方面有所发展，但对于欧洲国家来说，这一切都很直接。法西斯标志无处不在，被印在门票上。门票的设计和印刷标准极高，这样人们就可以把它们带回家。因此，这是在构建一种纪念品，也就是世界杯的这种视觉符号，而意大利人正处於核心地位，
this kind of idea of sporting merch or souvenirs to bring away with them. And of course, Mussolini put himself at the center of the imagery of this. He kind of ordered the construction of the artis, the fabrication of the Copa del Duce, this trophy that was six times bigger than the trophy that was to be given to the World Cup winner. So the Copa del Ducci will be presented to the winners alongside the World Cup.
这种体育周边商品或纪念品的理念让人们可以将其带走。当然，墨索里尼将自己置于这一切形象的中心。他下令建造和制造“领袖杯”（Copa del Duce），这个奖杯的大小是颁给世界杯冠军奖杯的六倍。因此，“领袖杯”将与世界杯一起颁发给冠军。
So that's a bit like Donald Trump's FIFA Peace Prize. Yes. Right. One of the most ironically titled awards in history. Yeah. So let's get to the finals themselves. Again, England don't go. They turn it down.
所以这有点像唐纳德·特朗普的国际足联和平奖。是的，没错。这是历史上最具有讽刺意味的奖项之一。是的。那么让我们来谈谈决赛本身。同样，英格兰没有去，他们拒绝了。
Interestingly, you don't, we were talking beforehand, you don't think this is a sign of, I mean, the characteristic thing that people say now in a sort of self-flagellating way that we love to do is, oh, this was a sign of insularity and arrogance. You don't necessarily think that? I think that it would be a fool who would argue that there wasn't a certain element of insularity and arrogance in it. There was a belief in the power still of British football, of the importance of the home international championship played every year.
有趣的是，正如我们之前讨论的那样，你不认为这是一个标志——我的意思是，现在人们喜欢以一种自我鞭挞的方式说出的典型特征是，哦，这标志着狭隘和傲慢。你并不一定这么认为吗？我认为，如果有人认为其中没有一定成分的狭隘和傲慢，那他就是个傻瓜。当时人们对英国足球的力量、以及每年举办的本土国际锦标赛的重要性仍然深信不疑。
And there was a certain arrogance involved in that. But I don't think that's the defining reason. I don't think that's the beginning and end of the conversation. because it's that classic thing that we do in history. We see an event the way it is now and we project its importance backwards. But in 1930, 1934, in the 1930s in general, the World Cup was very much in the making.
其中确实包含了一定程度的傲慢。但我认为这不是决定性的原因。我认为这并不是对话的全部。因为这是我们在历史研究中经常做的一个经典举动：我们以现在的眼光看待一个事件，并将其重要性投射到过去。但在1930年、1934年，以及整个20世纪30年代，世界杯还处于发展阶段。
FIFA was an organisation, which was still relatively speaking, an amateur organisation, which was only beginning to gather power. It wasn't clear who else was going to play, what really was involved in qualifying, or were you just invited to come? So I think it's wrong to say
国际足联当时还是一个相对而言的业余组织，其影响力才刚刚开始积聚。当时并不清楚还有谁会参赛，资格赛的具体内容是什么，或者你是否只是应邀前来？所以我认为说
that this is simply a mark of virgins and insularity. Some good teams do go. I guess the best team, the most obviously, you might have said the obvious favourites. Consider the best team, certainly the best European team of the 1930s, Austria, the Wunda team, as they were called. They were famous for something I think called the Whirl. I don't exactly know what that is, but basically,
这纯粹是傲慢和闭塞的标志是错误的。一些优秀的球队确实去了。我想最好的球队，最明显的，你可能会说是最热门的夺冠球队。被认为最好的球队，绝对是20世纪30年代最好的欧洲球队——奥地利队，也就是所谓的“梦幻之队”（Wunderteam）。他们以一种被称为“旋风”的战术而闻名，我不太清楚那具体是什么，但基本上，
they moved the ball very quickly, and they were a great team. Their manager, legendary figure called Hugo Meisel. They beat Scotland 5-0 in 1931, and Scotland were not nothing in those days. so impressive, but they obviously don't win it because we know that Austria have never won the World Cup. Italy win it. Italy's route to the final.
他们传球速度极快，是一支伟大的球队。他们的主教练是一位名叫雨果·迈塞尔（Hugo Meisel）的传奇人物。他们在1931年以5比0击败了苏格兰队，而苏格兰队在当时并非泛泛之辈。这令人印象深刻，但他们显然没有赢得冠军，因为我们知道奥地利从未赢得过世界杯。意大利赢了。意大利通往决赛的道路上，
There are a couple of incidents, aren't there? I mean, if we'll actually just go to the semi-final against the Austrians, Austria are the favorites. Would I be being too harsh in saying, now obviously there's an issue here, which is that we can't watch the game, so we're reliant on reports. But as far as we can tell,
发生了一些小插曲，对吧？我的意思是，如果我们直接来看看对阵奥地利的半决赛，奥地利是夺冠热门。如果我说——当然这里有一个问题，那就是我们无法观看那场比赛，所以只能依靠报道，但在我看来，
would I be too harsh in saying that Italy kicked their way to victory? in a game that was dubiously refereed. One of the, I suppose, enduring threads of the World Cup and its history is the claim that almost every country who got there did so by either having accommodating referees on their side, having opponents who had been bought off, or having kicked the tower out of anyone who got in their way. And of course, the truth of it is that every successful international team
如果我说意大利是用暴力踢出了一条胜利之路，会不会太过分？那场比赛的裁判执法也颇受质疑。世界杯及其历史中贯穿始终的一个持久主题是，几乎每个走到最后的国家，要么是因为有顺从的裁判帮忙，要么是买通了对手，要么就是把任何挡路的人狠狠踢翻。当然，事实是每一个成功的国际团队，
has a really good administeral of people beside them who make sure or push to get a game played in a particular place with a particular referee. That's understood. It is also the case that physical fitness and physical strength was absolutely, it is not possible to win a World Cup without being physically ready.
身边都有一群非常出色的行政人员，他们确保或力求在特定地点、由特定裁判进行比赛。这是可以理解的。同样事实的是，体能和身体对抗绝对是至关重要的，没有良好的身体状态就不可能赢得世界杯。
And we'll see that when it comes to the Brazilian teams of the 60s and 70s and the Argentinian teams later on. So what was it particularly that allowed Italy win? There is no doubt that Austria and Hungary, were more technically capable than Italy. Austrian and Hungarian coaches were coming to Italy to coach the players in Italy, but no foreign players beyond the Argentine or the South Americans were allowed play in the Italian competition.
我们在60和70年代的巴西队以及后来的阿根廷队身上也会看到这一点。那么，究竟是什么让意大利能够取胜呢？毫无疑问，奥地利和匈牙利在技术上比意大利更胜一筹。奥地利和匈牙利教练来到意大利执教意大利球员，但除了阿根廷人或南美球员外，没有外国球员被允许参加意大利的联赛。
So what did the Italians do? Well, they boasted their squad with five Rimpatriati. Oh, South Americans into the Italian team who were brilliant players. And that was crucial. So they had a technical ability that was outstanding. second of all, they had themselves a brilliant coach in Puzzo who had devoted themselves to the construction of the teams. And although Puzo wrote a letter after the semi-final to the best Austrian player Sindler, who does seem to have been kicked around the place during that game, a letter of apology to him,
那么意大利人做了什么？嗯，他们的阵容中有五名归化球员（Rimpatriati）。哦，那些表现出色的南美球员加入了意大利队，这至关重要。因此，他们的技术能力非常出色；其次，他们拥有一位杰出的教练波佐（Pozzo），他全身心投入到球队的建设中。尽管波佐在半决赛后给奥地利最好的球员辛德勒（Sindler）写了一封道歉信，后者在那场比赛中似乎确实遭到了粗暴对待，
the reality of it was he did what he needed to do to win, which was to make it a really physical game against Austria and to squeeze out a 1-0 victory. and there's been all sorts of comment about Eklund, the Swedish referee, who also reft in the 38th and 1950 finals, it should be said, as well. So this was a man who is devoted to soccer. There's a whole world of difference between pushing to have a referee who suits your style referee in the final and buying off that referee on the wayhands. And this is like so many of the supposed bribery stories in the World Cup or there's so many stories of chicanery. it remains case unproven and probably unprovable. Yeah, it's so interesting, isn't it?
但现实是，他做了他需要做的事情来赢得比赛，那就是与奥地利进行一场极具身体对抗的比赛，并以1比0险胜。关于瑞典裁判埃克隆德（Eklund），人们有各种各样的评论，值得一提的是，他在1938年和1950年的决赛中也担任裁判。所以这是一个对足球充满献身精神的人。为了迎合自己风格而争取某个裁判执法决赛，与在比赛途中买通裁判，这两者之间有着天壤之别。就像世界杯中许多所谓的行贿故事或许多阴谋诡计一样，
We were talking about this before we started recording that so many of the so-called scandals associated with the World Cup, so many of the allegations of bribery, corruption, match fixing and so on, when you trace them back, there's often a single source, much late, long after the game has taken place,
这依然是一个证据不足且可能无法证实的事例。是的，这非常有趣，不是吗？我们在录制前讨论过，许多与世界杯相关的所谓丑闻，许多关于行贿、腐败、打假球等指控，当你追溯它们的源头时，往往只有一个单一的来源，而且是在比赛结束很久之后才出现的，
which is then amplified by subsequent reports, and it becomes, it's kind of like an urban legend that crosses the line into historical fact because sports historians and journalists and whatnot and websites love to repeat it. And do you think that's a little bit the case with Italy in in 1934 that perhaps it's an old thing to say about a fascist team that's winning for Mussolini? Perhaps they've been a little bit hard done by by posterity? So first of all, it's a knockout competition.
随后又经过后续报道的放大，最终变成了一种都市传说，跨越了界限变成了历史事实，因为体育历史学家、记者以及各种网站都喜欢重复这些内容。你认为1934年的意大利队也是这种情况吗？也许对于一支为墨索里尼赢得胜利的法西斯球队来说，这种说法有些陈旧？也许后人对他们有些苛刻了？首先，这是一场淘汰赛。
So they're only playing four games. We have no video footage worthy of the name that survives. The accounts that have been handed down are partial. they are fragmentary and they're utterly unconvincing in their claims of chicanery that are involved in it. Did they do everything they could
所以他们只踢了四场比赛。我们没有留下任何称得上是视频资料的东西。流传下来的记载是不完整的，是零碎的，而且它们在宣称其中涉及欺骗时是极其缺乏说服力的。他们是不是尽了他们所能
to try and win? Yes, is it more than that? The evidence just simply doesn't stack up. I think there's two essential points that you made there that I agree with. First of all, the sources of these stories that are repeated time and again, I'm a big believer in oral history,
去争取胜利？是的，事情不止于此吗？这些证据根本站不住脚。我认为你刚才提出的两点核心观点我是赞同的。首先，这些被一遍又一遍重复的故事的来源，我是口述历史的坚定信仰者，
but I like a bit more than one single source. And it's not just that the idea of there being conspiracies is something that's part of the human. condition, it's most easier to imagine that your team has lost because of a conspiracy against it, as against the fact that they're simply not good enough. Yeah. So they get to the final.
但我更喜欢不止一个单一来源。而且不仅仅是阴谋论这种想法是人类本性的一部分，想象你的球队输球是因为针对它的阴谋，比承认他们单纯不够优秀要容易得多。是的。所以他们进入了决赛。
They play Czechoslovakia, of course, not yet dismembered by the Munich Agreement. And the Czechs actually went one nil up. So we're 20 bad 20 minutes to go. And hit the post. And hit the post. But then Orsi, who is actually one of the South Americans, right? Yeah, he's Argentinian. He beats a couple of men and scores a great goal.
他们对阵捷克斯洛伐克，当然，当时还没有被《慕尼黑协定》肢解。捷克人实际上取得了1比0的领先。所以比赛还剩20分钟，差一点进球。差一点进球。但随后奥尔西，他实际上是南美球员之一，对吧？是的，他是阿根廷人。他过掉几个人并打进了一个精彩的进球，
and then it goes to extra time. The first World Cup Final to go to Extra Time and a guy called Skiyavio hits the winner. 2-1. Bingo, they've done it. Harrah for Mussolini, hurrah for Italy. Jules Rimei, the founder of the World Cup, gives them the trophy.
然后比赛进入加时赛。第一场进入加时赛的世界杯决赛，一个叫斯基亚维奥的人打入了制胜球。2比1。宾果，他们做到了。墨索里尼万岁，意大利万岁。世界杯的创始人朱尔斯·里米把奖杯颁给了他们。
Mussolini gives them his Donald Trump trophy. And the Italian press go absolutely berserk, and they? And this proved this to them is not just a sporting triumph, but a moral and political triumph? Gazeta de la Sporal. goes, Italy is at the heart of the sports world. So this is evidence of the greatness of the
墨索里尼把他的唐纳德·特朗普奖杯颁给了他们。意大利媒体彻底疯狂了，他们？这证明了对他们而言这不仅是一场体育上的胜利，更是一场道德和政治上的胜利？《体育米兰报》写道，意大利处于世界体育的中心。所以这是
Italian male when it comes to the world stage. And you also have Il Bargelo coming out and saying that victory was the affirmation of an entire people, an indication of its virile and moral strength. So this is a projection which goes way beyond just a sporting success into the success of a nation. Mussolini delighted, the regime delighted. The obvious question, though, which may have occurred to some listeners already, I mean, most people don't go to the games, right, because you can only fit 60,000 people into a stadium or whatever.
意大利男性在世界舞台上展现伟大的证明。你还有《巴杰洛报》出来说，这场胜利是一个全体人民的肯定，是其强悍与道德力量的象征。所以这是一种投影，它远远超出了纯粹的体育成功，上升到了一个国家的成功。墨索里尼欣喜若狂，政权欣喜若狂。不过，显而易见的问题可能已经浮现在一些听众的脑海中，我的意思是，大多数人并没有去现场看球，对吧，因为你只能容纳6万人进球场或者别的什么。
So how do they... It's not clear either that the game sold out. Oh, my gosh. Which is really interesting because although Mussolini presented himself as queuing for a ticket before one of the games, broader public interest, a lot of people experienced it on the radio or looking at newsreels, but actually attending the game, was limited in numbers, and it's not clear that all the games sold out despite claims to the
那么他们是如何……而且也不清楚比赛是否售罄。哦，天哪。这真的很有趣，因为尽管墨索里尼表现得好像在其中一场比赛前排队买票一样，但更广泛的公众兴趣——很多人是通过广播或观看新闻短片来体验的——而实际去现场观看的人数是有限的，而且并不清楚所有比赛都售罄了，尽管有人宣称
contrary. Interesting. Well, this actually gets to the heart of what I was going to say. How do most people experience this? Because you've already mentioned two seismic technological developments so important in the politics of the early 20th century and so vital to dictatorships in particular, which are newsreels and radio. So most people presumably experiencing this, well, actually three ways. They'll hear it on. on the radio, they'll see it at the cinema in a newsreel, and then, and they'll also have, I've read about it in the newspaper and a magazine. Yes, that's, and they will have seen the posters that are up, the visual imagery, these brilliant Italian propagandist posters that are
相反。有趣。好吧，这实际上切中了我要说的核心。大多数人是如何体验这一点的？因为你已经提到了两项对20世纪早期政治极其重要、对独裁统治尤其至关重要的技术发展，它们就是新闻短片和广播。所以大多数人大概是通过这几种方式体验的，实际上是三种方式。他们会通过广播听到，他们会在电影院的新闻短片中看到，然后，他们还会通过报纸和杂志读到它。是的，就是这样，他们会看到张贴的海报，视觉意象，这些精彩的意大利宣传海报
put up and identified and done with such clarity and skill. But the rise of radio was, was so important because if you think about it, it allowed the voice to reach into someone's kitchen and increasing numbers of Italians had radios by the mid-1930s. I know radio was beginning to broadcast live sport by the early 1920s in America and then across Europe into 24
被张贴出来，设计得如此清晰和精湛。但是广播的兴起是如此重要，因为如果你想想看，它让声音能够传到某个人的厨房里，到20世纪30年代中期，越来越多的意大利人拥有了收音机。我知道广播在20世纪20年代初就开始在美国广播现场体育赛事，然后传遍欧洲直到24年
and then across to Australia. But the reality of it was that mass radio ownership was really a product from the mid-1930s onwards. So by 34 in Italy, more and more Italians, had radios and there is that public square broadcast so that it could be experienced in a communal way
然后传到澳大利亚。但现实情况是，大众拥有收音机实际上是20世纪30年代中期以后的产物。所以在34年的意大利，越来越多的意大利人有了收音机，并且有那种公共广场广播，这样人们也可以选择以一种集体的方式来体验它
in public squares by people as well who chose to do that. Before that, people used to congregate outside newspaper offices and wait for telegrams to come through with the, it's like the old video printer on. The stories of people doing at the 1930 World Cup in Buenos Aires, they're so excited and their face is dropping
在公共广场上，那些选择这样做的人。在此之前，人们习惯于聚集在报社外面，等待电报传过来，就像旧的电传打字机一样。1930年世界杯在布宜诺斯艾利斯人们这样做的故事，他们是如此兴奋，以至于他们的脸垮了下来
as a Eurocoy keeps scoring goals. And the way they did it, in 1930 in Buenos Aires was the tap comes true, but they have a loudspeaker set up outside to project the thousands of people who've gathered and the just these stories of the tears that flowed after your quote. Why are you laughing at the Argentinians, Stan Lackens?
当乌拉圭不断进球时。他们这样做的方式，1930年在布宜诺斯艾利斯，电报传过来，但他们在外面设置了扩音器，向聚集的数千人广播，还有那些在乌拉圭进球后流下的眼泪的故事。斯坦·拉肯斯，你为什么在嘲笑阿根廷人？
Go on, it's part of it. People would think there was something wrong with me if I didn't laugh at the Argentinians release in the 1930 World Cup final. On the radio issue, so so interesting that the commentator is, called Niccolo Corosio, and he replaces English terms then current in Italy, goal kick forward, and so on.
得了吧，这也是其中的一部分。如果我不嘲笑在1930年世界杯决赛中失利的阿根廷人，人们会觉得我有什么毛病。关于广播的问题，太有趣了，那个评论员叫尼科洛·卡罗西奥，他用意大利语术语替换了当时在意大利流行的英语术语，比如球门球、前锋等等。
The word daisy cutter with Italian terminology because of the Italianization of the game, I guess. Yeah, and this Italianization was really interesting as well. It's even the adoption of the word Calcio. So it's not football or it's not football as it became in South America, but Calcio takes on. And of course, this is an echo back to Calcio Fiorentina, the medieval game that was played, or the early modern game in Florence still like reenacted now with new teams and how important was there. It was this construction of a mythology that that itself was a recreation of Harpest and the Old Roman game. So this is Italy remaking in the 30s what had been already there in the early modern period, which itself was an extension of. of the old Roman world.
由于游戏的意大利化，我猜用意大利语术语代替了低平快传球。是的，这种意大利化也真的很有趣。甚至连“Calcio”这个词的采用也是如此。所以它不是足球，也不是南美洲那样的足球，而是演变成了Calcio。当然，这呼应了佛罗伦萨传统足球（Calcio Fiorentina），那是佛罗伦萨中世纪或早期现代的游戏，现在仍然由新球队重新上演，它有多重要？这是构建一种神话，而神话本身就是对哈帕斯托姆和古罗马游戏的再创造。所以这是意大利在30年代重塑那些在早期现代就已经存在的东西，而这本身就是古罗马世界延伸的一部分。
So it's not alone that we kind of, we've been at this game for thousands of years, but we're not having the mere English with their words. Right. Coming, infecting how our commentary, which is reaching into homes, because this is about Italy. Yeah, because if you're Mussolini in the mid-1930s,
所以不仅是我们参与这项运动已经有几千年了，而且我们不需要英国人及其词汇。对吧。进来，影响我们的评论，这些评论正在深入千家万户，因为这是关于意大利的。是的，因为如果你是20世纪30年代中期的墨索里尼
you don't want people thinking this is the game of Stanley Baldwin and Neville Chamberlain that we're trivying out. You want them to think this is an ancient Roman game with the heirs to the Roman Empire, you know, we are taking up the baton from our predecessors, which they have to be, I mean, they've won the World Cup. Yeah, football came home. Yeah, right.
你不会希望人们觉得这就像是斯坦利·鲍德温和内ville·张伯伦的博弈，被我们拿来当儿戏。你会希望他们觉得这是一场古罗马的游戏，参与者是罗马帝国的继承人，你知道的，我们在接力前人的火炬——毕竟，他们必须是这样，我的意思是，他们赢得了世界杯。是的，足球回家了。对，没错。
But that's what they'd say anyway. Although, it's slightly more complicated, isn't it? Because there are some fascists who don't like football because it's English. I mean, there's the issue of the fact that, you know, they've got South American players in the team who are, if you believe in blood and soil, Italian nationalism, it's a slight problem that some of your best players are not actually Italian. Then there's also people who are anti-fascists. There's a lot of anti-fascists in Italy.
但他们无论如何都会这么说。不过，情况要稍微复杂一些，不是吗？因为有些法西斯分子并不喜欢足球，因为它来自英国。我的意思是，这里有个问题，你知道的，他们的球队里有南美球员，如果你相信血统与土地、意大利民族主义，那么你的一些最优秀的球员其实并不是意大利人，这就成了一个小问题。此外，还有反对法西斯的人。意大利有很多反法西斯人士。
How do they react to the 1934 World Cup? So even within fascism, there's an ambiguity around soccer. And you can see it by the invention of a game by the National Secretary of the Fascist Party, Augusto Turati, who set up a game which was loosely based around. the rules of soccer, but which was called Volata, and it was to be the kind of a fascist, the fascist version of stock didn't kick off. Sort of quidditch of, yes, exactly, yeah.
他们对1934年世界杯作何反应？所以，即使在法西斯主义内部，对足球也存在一种含糊不清的态度。从法西斯党全国书记奥古斯托·图拉蒂（Augusto Turati）发明的一种运动中就能看出来，他设立了一种大致基于足球规则的游戏，但被称为“沃拉塔”（Volata），它将成为一种法西斯版本的……比赛并没有踢起来。某种没有扫帚的魁地奇，是的，完全正确。
Quidditch without the broomstick as you go wrong. And that just did not take off. So that's within the party itself. You then have that addition of the RIMPatriati, which of course is made really more difficult for those people who brought them in by the fact that some of those RIM patriotti disappeared from the country in 35 and then into 36. when the invasion of Ethiopia and everything that came like that
没有扫帚的魁地奇，你走错了方向。那个运动根本没有流行起来。所以这是党内的情况。接着，你又遇到了“归侨”（Rimpatriati）的问题，当然，对于那些把他们引进国内的人来说，由于其中一些归侨在1935年以及随后的1936年（也就是入侵埃塞俄比亚以及诸如此类的事情发生时）从这个国家消失了，这使得他们的工作变得更加困难
and there's military service on the way. So that creates a problem. And then you have the idea of Carlo Leverie writing in 1934, lamenting the fact that sport has now been used as propaganda, lamenting the fact that it's infantilizing a nation into acceptance of a regime which he utterly opposes and which he fought against. And I do think in all of this, you have to remember that it's a real, danger that you believe the propaganda. So that is to say we accept that there was propaganda,
而且接下来还有兵役问题。这就产生了一个问题。然后，你还有卡洛·莱维（Carlo Levi）在1934年写下的观点，他哀叹体育现在正被用作宣传工具，哀叹这正在使一个民族陷入幼稚化，从而接受一个他极端反对并曾与之战斗过的政权。我确实认为，在所有这些事情中，你必须记住，这里存在一个真正的危险，那就是你信了宣传。也就是说，我们承认存在宣传，
but to move from that to say that the propaganda was successful is problematic. And you see it with, for example, Lucio Lombardo Redici, the celebrated mathematician and communist from the 1930s in Italy, he wrote later of those years saying he had been at the matches. He was at the final in which the checks were beaten. And he said of that he was disdainful. This is a communist who was disdainful of the idea that it was a fascist enterprise. He said, no one ever became fascist because they supported Vittorio Pozo's Italian team. And he went down, he went on and he questions it said, this words of opium for the masses or the corruption of consciousness and souls. And then he says, not at all. Please stop talking nonsense. So this is a really interesting thing. And I know you have a
但从这一点出发，进而认为宣传取得了成功，那就成问题了。比如卢西奥·隆巴多·拉迪奇（Lucio Lombardo Radice）就是一个例子，他是20世纪30年代意大利著名的数学家和共产主义者，他后来在谈到那些年代时写道，他曾去现场观看过比赛。捷克斯洛伐克队被打败的那场决赛他在场。关于那场比赛，他表示自己充满蔑视。这是一个对“这是一项法西斯事业”的观点感到蔑视的共产主义者。他说，没有人会因为支持维托里奥·波佐（Vittorio Pozzo）的意大利队而变成法西斯分子。接着他继续质疑，说这些是麻痹大众的鸦片，还是对意识和灵魂的腐蚀。然后他说，根本不是这回事。请别再胡说八道了。所以这是一个非常有趣的事情。我知道你对此有
strong view on this. The standard interpretation is that, Nasty regimes use sport and culture to brainwash the masses, and the masses duly fall into the line. They love bread and circuses, and that's just how it works. And this is basically this entire series that we're doing is quite a simple, top-down story of nasty generals using sport to control the public. And you think that's not correct, that it's more complicated than actually the public either are not interested in that they don't see the political angle. it's irrelevant, they're not interested, or they resist it, or they can, they simultaneously, that people are more complicated and people can support Argentina winning in 1978 while still hating their regime, let's say.
强烈的看法。传统的解释是，纳粹政权利用体育和文化来给大众洗脑，而大众也顺从地听从摆布。他们热爱面包和马戏，事情就是这样运作的。基本上我们正在做的整个系列节目就是一个相当简单的、自上而下的故事，讲述残暴的将领们如何利用体育来控制公众。而你认为这是不正确的，实际情况要复杂得多：要么公众根本不感兴趣，或者他们看不到政治角度；这与他们无关，他们不感兴趣，要么他们进行抵抗，或者他们能够——人们其实更加复杂，人们可以一边支持阿根廷在1978年赢得世界杯，一边同时憎恨他们的政权，比方说。
I suppose I don't like a history which is a mass ascription of either motivation or impact onto great swades of people within any country. That would be my starting point. Now it would be a fool who would argue that it had no impact. So I'm not trying to argue that in any shape or form. And what I argue for is a more tempered understanding and a more nuanced understanding of how this actually worked. And I think there are a series of questions that are worth asking in relation to this. So in what way would Italy and Italian society and fascism have behaved differently if the World Cup had not been played and won in 34 and in 36 or 38?
我想我不喜欢那种将某种动机或影响大规模强加给任何国家广大民众的历史。这将是我的出发点。现在，如果有人争辩说这毫无影响，那他就是个傻瓜。所以我并不是想以任何形式或形状去争辩这一点。我所主张的是，对这一切实际上是如何运作的，要有更温和、更细致的理解。我认为，围绕这一点有一系列问题值得探讨。那么，如果1934年、1936年或1938年的世界杯没有举办也没有赢得，意大利、意大利社会以及法西斯主义的行为方式会有什么不同？
In 36 with the Berlin Olympics when they won the soccer and 38 when they won the World Cup again. do we imagine because of that that Italy would not have gone into war with Germany and moved on? Would the non-staging of the Berlin Olympics in 36 really have altered the course of Nazi Germany? Similarly, the Brazilian military dictatorship, which oversaw the winning of the World Cup in 1970, by the end of the 70s, its power was in severe decline. And we'll talk about how that manifested South Dominic in the next episode. But equally, in 78, Argentina won the World Cup. the military dictatorship was gone. And this is the thing that must be remembered always about sport.
在1936年柏林奥运会上，他们赢得了足球比赛，而在1938年，他们又赢得了世界杯。难道我们会因为这个就设想意大利不会与德国开战并继续向前吗？1936年柏林奥运会的停办真的会改变纳粹德国的历史进程吗？同样，巴西军政府在1970年监督并赢得了世界杯，但到70年代末，其权力已经严重衰落。我们将在下一集里讨论这在南美是如何体现的。但同样地，在1978年，阿根廷赢得了世界杯，军政府却下台了。关于体育，有一点是必须永远铭记的。
Sport, at its very best, is of the moment. It completely captures the emotions in the moment. But what does that mean beyond the moment? What is the legacy of that success? Is it eaten bread soon forgotten when it comes to sport? Sport is unbelievably protein in its aspect. It changes and turns all the time. It is always driving forward. And it is always about the next event, not the one that has just happened or very quickly becomes about the next to then. Now, I'm not saying that it doesn't facilitate identification, but it doesn't smother all other feelings. And it does not, you cannot deny the multiple identities of a human being when it comes to these things. I actually couldn't agree with you more. I think it's clearly the people who go to the games, they've got fascist
体育，在它最好的状态下，是属于当下的。它完全抓住了当下人们的情感。但超越当下这意味着什么？这种成功的遗产是什么？当谈到体育时，是不是吃过饼干就忘了？体育在它的各个方面简直像变形虫一样善变。它一直在改变和转向，一直在向前推进。它永远关乎下一场比赛，而不是刚刚过去的那场，或者说它很快就会变成关乎下一场比赛。现在，我并不是说它没有促进认同感，但它并没有压制所有其他的情感。而且毫无疑问，当涉及到这些事情时，你无法否认人类的多重身份。实际上，我不能同意你更多了。我认为很明显，那些去现场看球的人，他们手里拿着印有法西斯标志的
printed tickets, then fascist stadiums. There are lots of fascists there. But that doesn't mean that they're all complicit in the regime, although they have unthinkingly swallowed their propaganda. For me, that's a classy example of historians looking at a great mass of people who are not historians and saying, ultimately, they're easily brainwashed because they're all idiots. I think that's right. In a nutshell, that's it. Yeah. Okay, so you said sports about the next thing. So is this podcast. The next thing is the 1936 Olympics, which might seem an odd thing to introduce in the story of the World Cup. But Italy, as you said, they win the football gold medal at the 1936. Olympics. And for Mussolini, he takes this just as seriously as the World Cup, would you say?
门票，坐在法西斯修建的体育场里。那里有很多法西斯分子。但这并不意味着他们全都是该政权的同谋，尽管他们是不经思考地吞下了宣传。对我来说，这是一个典型的例子：历史学家看着一大群不是历史学家的人，然后说，归根结底，他们很容易被洗脑，因为他们都是白痴。我认为这话没错。简而言之，就是这样。Yeah。好吧，既然你说了体育是关于下一件事的。这个播客也是如此。下一件事是1936年奥运会，在世界杯的故事中引入这一点可能看起来有些奇怪。但正如你所说，意大利人在1936年奥运会上赢得了足球金牌。对墨索里尼来说，他对待这事的严肃程度不亚于世界杯，你会这么认为吗？
I think the fact of going to Germany and that kind of developing relationship with Hitler, which comes after 36 onwards and everything that happens in the way Italian society is beginning to change and move closer to Germany, albeit with resistance from quite a number of Italian people who don't like this. They don't like this drift of Italian policy. So the 36 Olympic Games was played, there was a soccer competition, which was won by the Italians with a group of students. And again, this is looking forward. The Italians had staged the world student games twice under Mussolini. So this is about the creation of a new generation who are coming in imbued with these ideas that would not just be Italian students who are thinking these things, but also students who come
我认为，去德国访问的事实，以及那种与希特勒不断发展的关系（这种关系从36年开始发展，随之而来的是意大利社会开始发生变化并向德国靠拢的一切，尽管遭到了相当多不喜欢这一点的意大利人的抵抗，他们不喜欢意大利政策的这种走向）——所以，1936年奥运会举行了，其中有一场足球比赛，由意大利的一群学生赢得了冠军。再次强调，这是面向未来的。在墨索里尼的统治下，意大利已经两次举办了世界大学生运动会。因此，这是关于创造新一代的人，他们带着这些思想来到这里，这些思想不仅会留在那些思考这些事情的意大利学生心中，还会留在那些从
from around the world to come to Italy, to see the success of it and bring home to their countries, a benign understanding and indeed a kind of a certain awe of what has been created in this new Rome, which is shown on the newsreels that we see around the place. So he sends a team there, an Italian Olympic team that come forth, but they win the soccer and they play really, really well. And it is true, though, it's at a different level because the soccer in the World Cup by this point is restricted to amateurs, whereas the soccer in the Olympic Games is restricted to amateurs, whereas in the World Cup, it's professionals. So the next World Cup, 1938, this is held in France, final in Paris.
世界各地来到意大利的学生心中，他们亲眼目睹了这里的成功，并把对这个新罗马所创造的事物的温和理解、甚至某种敬畏带回自己的国家，这些都在我们周围看到的滑铁卢新闻短片中得到了展示。因此，他派去了一支意大利奥运代表队，他们获得了第四名，但他们赢得了足球比赛，并且踢得非常、非常好。而且确实如此，不过这是在不同的层面上，因为此时世界杯的足球赛仅限于业余球员，而奥运会的足球赛也仅限于业余球员，但在世界杯上，参赛的是职业球员。所以下一届世界杯，即1938年世界杯，在法国举行，决赛在巴黎。
FIFA had chosen France over Germany to host the World Cup. I mean, I see it's an interesting alternative history, isn't it, where the World Cup 1938 is actually in Germany. But anyway, it's in France. France, for most of the 20th century, actually, well, indeed, for almost all the 20th century, France is not a big footballing nation at all. Bigger in rugby. Much rugby and cycling, I guess, France's sports.
国际足联选择了法国而不是德国来主办世界杯。我的意思是，我觉得这是一个有趣的另类历史，不是吗？如果1938年世界杯真的在德国举行的话。但无论如何，它是在法国。在20世纪的大部分时间里，或者说几乎在整个20世纪里，法国其实根本不是一个足球大国。橄榄球更厉害。橄榄球和自行车运动，我想这才是法国的体育。
I mean, some mad teams actually Cuba are there. The Dutch East Indies are there. Italy, of course, are there again. One of the big European teams, not there because it doesn't exist anymore, Austria. And you might say Germany will be brilliant in the 1938 World Cup because they've absorbed the Austrians. But actually, the Anceles turns out to be a sporting problem rather than an asset because it's very difficult for them to integrate the Austrians into the German team. Is that right?
我的意思是，有些疯狂的球队也去了，比如古巴。荷属东印度群岛也去了。当然，意大利又去了。欧洲的一大强队没有去，因为它已经不复存在了，那就是奥地利。你可能会说德国在1938年世界杯上会表现出色，因为他们吞并了奥地利。但实际上，“德奥合并”（Anschluss）结果成了一个体育上的难题，而不是一项资产，因为要将奥地利球员整合到德国队中是非常困难的。是这样吗？
Yeah, they try and basically take half of one team, put it with half of the other team, and anybody who's ever managed a sports team knows just how difficult that is, but it is so striking. The 36 Berlin Olympics final, Italy beat Austria 2-1, and Austria doesn't even exist by the time of the 38 World Cup when it comes to playing. They're absorbed into it. And this World Cup, this 38 World Cup is really interesting. It is, I think we have to say it's something of an afterthought from 34.
是的，他们基本上试图把其中一支球队的一半人拿过来，和另一支球队的一半人拼凑在一起，任何管理过运动队的人都知道这有多么困难，但这又是如此引人注目。1936年柏林奥运会决赛中，意大利以2比1击败奥地利，而到了1938年世界杯开打时，奥地利甚至已经不复存在了。他们被吞并了。这场世界杯，1938年的这场世界杯真的很有趣。我认为我们必须说，它有点像是1934年世界杯的后续产物。
And it's interesting to look at it about what's going to come, about what comes next. And you can see Italian anti-fascist protesters booed the Italian team when they arrive into play their games in France. And I think that's a reminder. I think that no country is ever one thing or another at a particular time. And that although you may identify with the national team and how wins, you can also use it to display your displeasure as well as your pleasure. Yeah. But the Italians win again with a completely different thing.
回顾它将带来什么、接下来会发生什么，是很有趣的。你可以看到，当意大利队抵达法国准备比赛时，意大利的反法西斯抗议者发出嘘声嘘他们。我认为这是一个提醒。我认为没有任何一个国家在特定时期内是单一形态的。尽管你可能会认同国家队及其胜利，但你也可以用它来表达你的不满，就像表达你的喜悦一样。是的。但意大利人又赢了，带着完全不同的阵容。
Yeah, just two players left. From the... From 34. So that is a tribute to Vittorio Potser, the manager, who's obviously a genuinely, you know, for only people who might say, this is rigged, that's rigged. He's obviously a fantastic manager if he can create two teams that win these international tournaments. He seems to have had an extraordinary capacity to motivate people to play together in a unit and to play together for Italy.
是的，只剩两个球员了。从……从34年留下的。所以这是对主教练维托里奥·波佐（Vittorio Pozzo）的致敬，他显然是一个真正的人，你知道的，对于那些可能会说“这被操纵了，那被操纵了”的人来说，如果他能打造出两支赢得这些国际锦标赛的球队，他显然是一个出色的教练。他似乎有一种非凡的能力，能够激励人们作为一个整体共同作战，并为意大利而战。
and to try and win. And, you know, all this talk about, oh, the Brazilians were bought off in 38. They didn't play their best player Leonidas in the semifinal. He scored a hat-trick in 6-5. He's supposed to have had a calf injury there. So it's so easy to look backwards and say the reality of it is Italy
并努力去赢得胜利。而且，你知道，所有关于“哦，巴西人在38年被收买了”的言论。他们在半决赛中没有让他们的最佳球员莱昂尼达斯（Leonidas）上场。他在6比5的比赛中上演了帽子戏法。据说他当时小腿受伤了。所以人们太容易回顾过去，然后说现实情况是意大利
when the final 4-2, there were a really, really strong team. There's just a lack of specificity about the supposed chicanery that went on. Yeah, because again, there's a claim Hungary basically through, the claim is that Hungary went all the way to the final, then through the final, madly because they were hoping for Italian help
以4比2赢得决赛，他们是一支非常、非常强大的球队。只是对于那些所谓的阴谋诡计，缺乏具体细节。是的，因为又有人声称匈牙利基本上是故意输掉的，声称匈牙利一路杀入决赛，然后莫名其妙地输掉了决赛，因为他们希望得到意大利的帮助
in revising the Treaty of Trianao, which just seems utterly implausible to me. I know the Treaty of Triennon is a big deal in Hungary because basically Hungary loses a lot of territory that thinks it's entitled to in Transylvania and stuff. But again, it's such an unspecific and vague claim that the players somehow miraculously scored goals but managed to throw the rest of the game.
来修改《特里亚农条约》，这在我看来简直完全不可信。我知道《特里亚农条约》在匈牙利是一件大事，因为基本上匈牙利失去了很多它认为自己理应拥有的领土，比如在特兰西瓦尼亚等地的领土。但同样，这是一个非常不具体且模糊的说法，即球员们一方面不知何故奇迹般地进球了，另一方面又设法把比赛的其余部分给踢输了。
It seems unlikely to me. It seems to me that it would be difficult to bring home that bribe if indeed you were being bought off on the strength of it. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. If you're like the right back in the Hungarian team, you get home to Budapest and you say, well, bad news is we lost the final. The good news is I'm pretty confident that in a few years, the Italians will help us get
这在我看来不太可能。在我看来，如果你真的是靠这个被收买的，要把这笔贿款带回家恐怕都很困难。是的。对，完全是这样。如果你就像匈牙利队的那个右后卫，你回到布达佩斯，然后你说，好吧，坏消息是我们输掉了决赛。好消息是我相当确信，几年后意大利人会帮我们把
chance of pain you back. So it does seem very unlikely. Okay, so let's just before we, as we wrap up. How do the Italians end up remembering all this? Because obviously, in Italy, after the Second World War, there's not really the same kind of denatification process that you get in West Germany. So the Italians don't have a great bout of self-flagellation
失去的机会赢回来。所以这看起来确实很不现实。好吧，那么在我们结束之前，让我们先谈谈。意大利人最终是如何记住这一切的呢？因为很显然，在意大利，二战之后并没有真正经历像西德那样彻底的去纳粹化进程。所以意大利人并没有经历那种深刻的自我鞭笞
and soul-searching. There's no sort of de-fascistification of Italy. They're happy to continue celebrating these World Cup wins. They didn't see them as at all, and inverted commas are problematic, do they? No, and it continued through to the, stage in the 1990 World Cup where you see Angelo Skiavio, who scored the winning goal in the 34 final. He gave an interview to Gazette de los sport before, where he said, before those finals,
和灵魂拷问。意大利没有进行某种去法西斯化。他们很高兴继续庆祝这些世界杯的胜利。他们一点也不觉得这些有什么问题，打引号的“有问题”对吗？没有，这种状态一直持续到1990年世界杯的阶段，在那里你可以看到安杰洛·斯基维奥（Angelo Schiavio），他打入了1934年决赛的制胜球。他在赛前接受《米兰体育报》（Gazzetta dello Sport）采访时说，在那些决赛之前，
where he said, I sincerely don't remember much of that day, the final that he's talking about. I actually learned the details I have forgotten only by reading the newspapers that talked about it. For example, that Mussolini was present. they said he was going to come but I hadn't noticed that from the field then the next day when we went to Palacio Palazzo Venezia where the
他说，对于那一天——他所谈论的那场决赛，我真诚地记不太清了。我实际上是通过阅读那些报道它的报纸，才了解并记起了那些我早已忘掉的细节。例如，墨索里尼曾到场。他们说他会来，但我当时在球场上并没有注意到这一点；然后第二天，当我们去威尼斯宫（Palazzo Venezia）时，那里的
famous balcony is he said some of us stretched out our hand to shake his but this wasn't so good because Mussolini raised his hand in the air greeting us with the Romans it was me who had scored the decisive goal but I got no special compliment so that's how he remembers it
那个著名的阳台，他说我们中的一些人伸出手去跟他握手，但这并不是很好，因为墨索里尼把手举在空中，用罗马礼向我们致意。进决定性球的人是我，但我并没有受到什么特别的赞扬。所以这就是他的记忆。
and he's put out there also Raiuno the main Italian television station in 1990. Six million people watched the documentary, sorry, a film that they made called Il Coloro de la Vittorio, which was the colour of victory about the 1934 World Cup. And it completely underplayed the fascistic context of the competition, as indeed does the National Football Museum in Covertiano in Florence.
而且不仅如此，1990年意大利国家电视台一台（Raiuno）也是如此。有六00万人观看了这部纪录片——抱歉，是一部他们制作的电影，名叫《胜利的色彩》（Il Colore della Vittoria），讲的是1934年世界杯时胜利的颜色。它完全淡化了这场比赛的法西斯背景，正如佛罗伦萨科维尔西亚诺（Coverciano）的国家足球博物馆所做的那样。
So you, and Pozzo wrote an autobiography, it didn't really mention the fascist element of, of the success and of course, Jules Rimei himself, the president of FIFA, he himself after the war, was really keen to downplay the notion of connections between FIFA and Italian fascism. But just a last question on this. Is that them airbrushing history? Or is that reinforcing your point that maybe posterity overblows the fascistic nature of this? And actually, if you were a player, you might, you know, you're so fixated on you. I mean, we know sportsmen and women are always very, very single-minded.
所以你，而且波佐写过自传，里面也没有真正提到成功的法西斯要素；当然，国际足联主席儒勒·雷米（Jules Rimet）本人，在战后也极力淡化国际足联与意大利法西斯主义之间的联系这一概念。但关于这一点，最后一个问题。这是他们在美化历史吗？还是说这印证了你的观点，即后人或许夸大了其中的法西斯性质？实际上，如果你是一名球员，你可能会，你知道的，你太专注于比赛了。我的意思是，我们知道运动员总是非常、非常专一的。
Perhaps they, I mean, as mad as it might sound, perhaps they didn't really notice that it was being co-opted by the fascist regime. And therefore, it was a surprise to them later on when they were told, actually your victory has been tarnished by its association in Mussolini. Oh, yeah, but the gap between the obsessive nature of an elite sportsperson, there's a huge space between that and the wider context. So I think to ignore the wider context while focusing just on the obsessive nature
也许他们——听起来可能很疯狂，也许他们并没有真正注意到自己正被法西斯政权所利用。因此，当他们后来被告知“实际上你们的胜利已经被与墨索里尼的联系玷污了”时，他们感到很惊讶。哦，是的，但是精英运动员的这种执着天性，与更广泛的背景之间存在着巨大的空间。所以，如果只关注精英运动员的执着天性而忽视更广泛的背景，就会错失一个机会，无法呈现一个有趣得多的故事：它既不是一场纯粹的法西斯世界杯，也不是一次纯粹的精英体育成功，而是这两者在某种交错的碎片中同时发生。
and elite sport misses the opportunity to render what is a kind of a much more interesting story which is neither just a fascist World Cup nor an elite sporting success but both happen in a kind of interlocking fragments. Okay, great. And very last question before we wrap up. Of course, next time we'll be talking about Brazil.
好的，太棒了。在结束之前的最后一个问题。当然，下一次我们要谈论的是巴西。
Callum, a producer, wants to know why Italy is so bad right now. Why haven't they qualified for the last three World Cups? It comes down, I think, to the collapse of the Italian League. Italy, even we'll all remember. We watched soccer in the 90s and into the 2000s, the strength of the Italian league, the strength of Italian club teams. So the collapse of serious, seriously competitive Italian teams,
我们的制作人卡勒姆（Callum）想知道为什么意大利现在这么差。为什么他们没有获得过去三届世界杯的资格？我认为这归结为意大利联赛的崩溃。意大利，我们大家都会记得。我们在90年代和2000年代观看足球比赛时，曾见证过意大利联赛的实力，意大利俱乐部球队的实力。因此，那些具有真正强大竞争力的意大利球队的崩溃，
the inability of the people, the clubs of Italy to attract the very best players in the world, has limited the success of the lead, has compressed it, and Italy simply does not produce enough good players themselves. Okay, fair enough. All right. So I really hope you enjoyed this first episode of the series. It's been a very exciting recording for us because right next door is the Belgian player, Eden Hazard.
意大利俱乐部无力吸引世界上最优秀的球员，这限制了联赛的成功，使其遭到压缩，而且意大利本身也无法产出足够多的优秀球员。好吧，很有道理。好的。所以，我真的很希望你们喜欢这个系列的第一集。对我们来说，这是一次非常令人兴奋的录音，因为就在隔壁房间，住着比利时球员埃登·阿扎尔（Eden Hazard）。
When he looked through the window and he saw Paul Rouse, he's like, Jesus, it's Paul Rouse. And we had to actually keep him at bay because he was so overexcited. Anyway, if you've enjoyed this first episode, head to The Restis History.com and join Eden. in Hazard in The Rest is History Club. He will be listening to the next two episodes in this series, and I hope you will too. Hello, everybody. Now, as those of you who are good children will know, here in Britain,
当他透过窗户看到保罗·劳斯时，他简直不敢相信：“天哪，是保罗·劳斯。”我们甚至不得不拦住他，因为他太兴奋了。不管怎样，如果你喜欢第一集，请访问 The Restis History.com 并加入 Eden. in Hazard 的 The Rest is History 俱乐部。他将收听本系列的接下来的两集，希望你也会。大家好。现在，正如你们这些乖孩子所知，在英国，
on the 21st of June, it's Father's Day. But not just here in Britain. It's also Father's Day on the 21st of June in the United States, in Canada, and in the Republic of Ireland. So those are four countries that are united by dads who love to listen to the rest is history. And that is why we are offering an amazing 25% Father's Day discount on the subscription price to the Rest is History Club, because we are all heart. So treat the Peter the Great in your own life this Father's Day to early access to, full series. You get early access, that you get that with the membership. You get bonus episodes. You get ad-free listening. You get access to tickets for live shows. Basically, you get an entire host of supplementary benefits. And that, I think, is what a lot of patriarchs want, isn't it?
6 月 21 日是父亲节。不仅在英国，美国、加拿大和爱尔兰共和国也在 6 月 21 日庆祝父亲节。这四个国家的共同点在于，父亲们都非常喜欢收听《历史的剩余》。正因如此，我们为“历史的剩余”俱乐部的订阅价格提供惊人的 25% 父亲节折扣，因为我们充满了关爱。在这个父亲节，为你生活中的“彼得大帝”送上全系列内容的抢先体验吧。你可以通过会员资格获得抢先体验，还可以获得加长节目、无广告收听、现场演出门票等福利。基本上，你会获得一整套附加福利。我想，这也是许多一家之主梦寐以求的，对吧？
It absolutely is because I think nothing says, happy Father's Day, quite like the chance to listen to six solid hours ad-free about the First World War. Yeah, that's what most fathers want. So head to the rest is history.com and click on the word gifts. And that gift, membership of our much loved Rest is History Club, will land straight in your father's inbox on Father's Day itself. So if you want to give the best Father's Day gift there's ever been in history, ever, and we say this as the presenters of the rest of history, you know what to do.
确实如此，因为没有什么比有机会连续六个小时无广告收听关于第一次世界大战的内容更能表达“父亲节快乐”了。是的，这正是大多数父亲想要的。所以请访问 therestishistory.com 并点击“礼物”一词。这份礼物——我们备受喜爱的“历史的剩余”俱乐部的会员资格——将会在父亲节当天直接发送到你父亲的收件箱里。所以，如果你想送出历史上最好的父亲节礼物——而且我们是以《历史的剩余》主持人的身份说这句话的——你知道该怎么做。
Hello, everybody. Now, as those of you who are good children will know, here in Britain, on the 21st of June, it's Father's Day. But not just here in Britain. It's also Father's Day on the 21st of June in the United States, in Canada, and in the Republic of Ireland. So those are four countries that are united by dads who love to listen to the rest is history. And that is why we are offering an amazing 25% Father's Day discount on the subscription price to the rest is history club because we are all heart. So treat the Peter the Great in your own life this Father's Day to early access to full series. You get bonus episodes. You get ad-free listening. You get access to tickets for live shows.
大家好。现在，正如你们这些乖孩子所知，在英国，6 月 21 日是父亲节。不仅在英国，美国、加拿大和爱尔兰共和国也在 6 月 21 日庆祝父亲节。这四个国家的共同点在于，父亲们都非常喜欢收听《历史的剩余》。正因如此，我们为“历史的剩余”俱乐部的订阅价格提供惊人的 25% 父亲节折扣，因为我们充满了关爱。在这个父亲节，为你生活中的“彼得大帝”送上全系列内容的抢先体验。你可以获得加长节目、无广告收听、现场演出门票。
Basically, you get an entire host of supplementary benefits. And that, I think, is what a lot of patriarchs want, isn't it? It absolutely is because I think nothing says happy Father's Day quite like the chance to listen to six solid hours, add free about the First World War. Yeah, that's what most fathers want. So head to the rest is history.com and click on the word gifts. And that gift, membership of our much-loved Restis History Club, will land straight in your father's inbox on Father's Day itself. So if you want to give the best Father's Day gift
基本上，你会获得一整套附加福利。我想，这也是许多一家之主梦寐以求的，对吧？确实如此，因为没有什么比有机会连续六个小时无广告收听关于第一次世界大战的内容更能表达“父亲节快乐”了。是的，这正是大多数父亲想要的。所以请访问 therestishistory.com 并点击“礼物”一词。这份礼物——我们备受喜爱的“历史的剩余”俱乐部的会员资格——将会在父亲节当天直接发送到你父亲的收件箱里。所以，如果你想送出父亲节礼物
that's ever been in history, ever, and we say this as the presenters of the Restis History, you know what to do. Finally, on day eight of the World Cup, England, play tonight. we've assembled a top team to work out how we win it. Harry McGuire and Micah Richards at the back, Georgia Stanway jinking in midfield, and it's Shearer and Lenica up top. Come and join us on The Rest is Football on Netflix.
这是历史上面世最好的礼物，而且我们是以《历史的剩余》主持人的身份说这句话的，你知道该怎么做。最后，在世界杯的第八天，英格兰队今晚将要比赛。我们组建了一支顶尖球队来探讨如何取胜。后防线上有哈里·马奎尔和迈卡·理查兹，中场有乔治娅·斯坦韦穿针引线，锋线上则是希勒和莱因克尔。快来 Netflix 上加入我们的《足球的剩余》吧。
Available right now. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现已上线。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。